now I looked up some of the players that  you are watching on youtube so i'ma list  them you tell me what you got from that  player some news you like from that  player that you tried incorporate ready  Carmelo Anthony I love how you know Melo  when he gets the ball in the mid post  and he like he uses his trigger step he  plays with people he just takes off he's  one of my favorite players Tracy McGrady  t-mac you know just how aggressive he  was attacking the basket if he's never  got hurt you really really really would  have been special ha I like how Paul  George is really shifty and with the  ball he was his in and out his crossover  he gets people off balance and he gets  to his spot he six nine if you shoot at  the best of them Kevin Durant KD just  really his mid post I like I eat heaps  throw to move from dirt one leg fade  away so he can shoot over anybody Kobe  Bryant everything I love anything about  Kobe as everybody already knows